Her low freak bitches.
How many years after retiring from boxing is Floyd Mayweather broke?
Uh,
the,
I mean,
the Conor fight alarms me,
uh,
five,
probably five.
Five.
Does he know all the company has 46?
No.
None of that shit soon.
You don't think so?
[inaudible] comeback fight at 46.
Nah.
It's just too sad.
His Ego's too big in,
the market's not there anymore.
I think he tries to talk Conor McGregor into a rematch.
I'm not kidding.
Do you see Conor statements about that?
No.
What he's saying,
he said I'd beat him in a rematch.
Adorable.
And I'll take God dammit.
Yeah.
Come on.
Well,
he would have to do something extremely different.
And his training,
no,
no.
There's,
it's just not,
he's never beating May,
whether in a boxing match,
it's just not possible.
He was punching him hard.
Right.
It looked like a,
he clipped him with that one hard upper cut,
but it looks like he was pacing himself and in saving his energy,
it's just that it's just not the way to go.
I get what he's doing,
but it's just not the way to go.
Yeah.
But if you're making $100 million,
it's $100 billion.
If he could sucker people into doing it again for $100 million.
Well what do you think the UFC is?
What do you think the UFC is going to have to do?
Conor back?
Because Connor Connor had his movie premiere,
which I guess destroy the box offices and not Ireland on a homie premiers they
have out there,
but it's the biggest,
most successful Irish movie of all time.
That's so crazy.
Yeah.
Which is crazy.
Um,
but they so crazy.
They asked him what did you have to do?
He goes,
oh we're not,
I don't have bosses anymore.
What we have to be partners,
which is a legit point.
Yeah.
It's a legit point.
He's a different business entity.
But I think part of the point is going to be that he can't talk about it.
It's I agree.
I think the deal is going to happen and then you just like,
no,
I'm fine.
Normal contract.
Cause UFC is like,
Yep,
we get it,
bitch.
We're going to give you some money.
There's also the issue if you're negotiating that you go public with this
negotiation like that.
You don't want to talk about that?
No.
I mean I guess he does for his brand because it makes them look like a super
ball.
They've got to pay corner now.
They can't just fucking keep wanting the same deal they had before.
Do you,
do you trust Conner not to say anything?
Well,
for Connor,
part thing is disclosing it.
It's part of his,
his swagger is how much money is what makes him Conor Mcgregor.
He's beating the game,
which is why we'd like to go.
Yeah,
it's go to be parody now.
Yeah.
It's got to have,
it can't be the order deal.
Yeah,
it can be the older deal.
So you think they'd give him a apart?
I think if I was at UFC I would do what it takes to be in the Conor McGregor
business.
Now I don't know what that means cause I don't know shit about business.
It means you're given a percentage of your company.
You got to give up a percentage.
If you want a percentage.
Okay,
look at 94% like this movie.
Fucking fucking amazing.
It's fucking amazing.
94% it's out Friday and all the movie theaters here,
I don't know about all,
but yeah,
I think a lot of them probably find those fucking 6% piece of Shite.
Jason through the streets of doable and just 6% and eight ds fans.
Yeah.
What is that about?
Who are these 6% fuck,
here's super haters,
right?
Pure haters.
Yeah.
Particulars.
So you're not getting the Nate fight.
Then if Tony and Conor fight,
say that again.
You're probably not getting the Nate fight any time soon.
If no cop cars team says to that Tony's the next fight,
which is management says that Dana says that.
So what do you do if your name,
I think they don't want to do an eight fight.
Who Does?
Oh,
Connor does it.
Ah,
I think,
ah,
I think they take,
Nate is a big fucking guy.
He's long.
He's a rough fight.
They had a for then Tony Ferg,
I think they're both rough fights there.
Bolt and neither one of them.
If I want to walk in the park,
but after coming off of that real hard fight with Nate,
maybe he thinks Tony's easier to hit.
No.
Oh.
Although,
well he hit made a lot too though.
Yeah,
he did hit Nate a lot,
but,
and it's at 55 but plot plus,
which is going to get more,
what's going to get more hype?
Nay.
I agree.
But,
and he was here.
He'd argue you to be going crazy.
Tony's a star.
He's just super star.
I went to Eddie.
You got relax.
Yeah.
But you know,
Eddie trains him to totally understand.
I want to say the same thing.
Honestly.
Want to see each fight equally.
I really do.
I don't have a favorite.
I would love to see Nate and Connor go at it again.
I would love to see Conor go at it with Tony.
I literally do not have a favorite.
I love both of those fights.
What happens if you only get,
you get one fight at a con,
kind of goes,
I'm only fighting once,
Tony,
I'm gonna let Joe Rogan be the guy on sides yet.
Tony Nader,
GSP.
Tony Tony is,
we haven't seen him fight Tony before.
We've seen him fight Nate twice.
GSP is such a long shot and it's a different weight class.
It's one 70 I mean that's all the GSP had talked about going to 55 at one point
in time.
Do you remember that?
Yeah.
Yeah,
that would,
that would take a long fucking time from,
from the people who I know who are super close with George,
what they want is Woodley and then a super fight with Conor.
That's their game plan.
Why do they want one thing?
70 champ going to vacate 85 [inaudible] 85 that make sense?
Dangerous fight.
Hell yeah,
but they're all dangerous.
All dangerous.
All of them.
Everybody wants 70 months.
That's just unrealistic.
They didn't happen in 70 makes more sense.
But look at what Dana said.
Don't call him a liar.
I'll call him right now.
Would you say he's in liar here.
He hates it.
Robert Whittaker here.
He hates me anyways,
so you can't get any worse.
So I don't give a fuck.
But I think he has to say that there's a lot of things where,
you know he's a PR.
Listen,
I know he's your friend,
but he's also a promoter.
He's the best runner in the game,
right?
So he has to say certain stuff.
So there's just not a wild west.
Maybe George really wants a fight.
Robert Whittaker.
It's entirely possible.
George really likes it at one 85 who knows?
I Dunno.
Not Happening.
Yeah,
I don't know.
It's not like take it.
It's not like,
yeah,
I'll take it.
It's not like Dana's word is bond here where,
you know,
he hasn't said outlandish shit before type of thing.
Let me ask you this.
What do you rather see?
You rather see him versus GSP versus Robert Whitaker or gs free versus Woodley?
Um,
God,
that's a great question.
I got my answer.
Yeah.
Winokur right.
It's so fucking exciting cause we can knock his ass out,
knock anybody out.
And he's aggressive and he's,
he's very technical.
He's striking his fucking wicked.
He's wicked.
But would I rather see?
Yeah.
I'd rather see Whitaker,
GSP,
if I,
if I'm on GSPS team,
he's fighting Woodley.
Really Wintergreen,
a fun fight for him.
I don't think either.
If it's a fun fight for anybody,
neither is fun.
But at 85 there,
there's a lot his stem.
Uh,
there's a lot that it's just not fun for him.
Well,
it's interesting because Robert Whitaker,
the 185 pounds interim champ used to be 170 pound fighter as well,
and he was stopped by Wonderboy.
Yeah,
that's true.
But he was draining himself to make one 70.
And Britta digger,
again,
we're talking about a 26 year old guy who when he changed weight classes was
probably only 23.
Right?
It was about three years ago.
Yeah.
This last loss,
right?
Yup.
Yeah.
He just couldn't make the weight training himself.
And it's harder to start when you're,
when you're older and he's pretty fucking stout at a,
at 185 pounds.
I mean,
he's not,
it's not small.
One 85.
He's the fastest 85 in the world.
Were you shocked by,
um,
Musashi Musashi fight?
Uh,
think that shows you like how good the bell tour guys are.
Yes and no.
I do,
I think bell tours at a level,
certain guys are level,
but I think Musashi if here's the interview and he was actually pretty funny in
it,
but he was like,
I had one fucking,
I'm it.
I literally had one night he closed my eye up so I was just going off instincts
and she'll Mancos very tough.
Very tough.
So I have one eye,
he stuffed.
That's what you get.
Yeah.
He caught him with one big clanger but he was,
he was pulling the brand and fairway,
he was like before even gather and was like,
I'm going to be champ at middle weight,
lightweight,
heavyweight and like,
oh,
I think everyone's going to go thug rose now.
I just want to be a good person.
Can't do this.
I want to be myself.
You can't do that.
Can kick your ass.
And she's like our father who art in heaven help,
you know,
some scary shit.
Really got room for one.
Right.
She did it though.
I know,
man.
Very happy.
Me Too.
That left Hook was,
that was the one of the most intriguing fights on the car to me.
I got to be on,
again,
I've known rose and we have a history in Denver and we had the same coaches and
I love rose and I bet on or just cause you're such a big underdog.
I,
and I predicted,
I thought she was gonna get,
she's going to be a lot of trouble because y'all hands just so goddamn
technical.
Yeah.
But I think Yolanda didn't respect her,
didn't she kinda overlooked her that that championship,
you know,
those,
those obligations you have as a champion.
I don't think people realize what comes with that.
You know,
a lot of people go,
everyone.
Yeah.
I think it was Dana said this or was run like,
everyone wants to be a champ too.
You have to do championships shit,
which you got to sell the fight.
You're the reason why the paper view is selling.
There's a lot that comes with that.
So,
and it's,
it's George retired because it,
he's like,
dude,
I can't relax man.
Yeah.
We don't get to see it very often too.
You know,
like we don't get to see it.
We see little clips here and there,
but we don't know what their schedule's like.
All the phone calls they have to manage all the interviews they have common or
talked about all day long.
I remember that he backed out of the,
when they wanted to do that fight,
he was like,
no,
fuck me.
I'm not doing all that media.
That's right man.
That's a killing me.
They were getting,
they pulled him from the car.
Yeah.
He was like,
cool,
I don't give a fuck.
I need to train.
Like you guys are having me do all this media circus stuff.
I gotta focus on the fight man.
And He,
and they put him through more energies and then anyone ever of course.
Cause he's never met a camera.
He doesn't like and think that.
He was like,
no,
I'm going crazy.
I remember when him and although they did that world tour.
Yeah,
that was ridiculous,
man.
That world over,
over,
over easy.
How about the F and then the f the Floyd Mayweather tour?
That was,
that schedule is nuts.
And I was just the commentator on that bitch.
I was exhausted.
Yeah.
How crazy was that?
That tour where they would stand in front of her but even talk shit,
I told that they shit after two cities.
It'd be tough for the best comics in the world.
Cup of new material,
six nights in a row,
little loan.
These two fighters,
like the first two cities you saw,
they had their shit together.
It was fun.
Then after that third one is like,
what are we doing?
What do you think?
What would they sell on tickets to that or they're giving it away for free.
I think they are giving them away,
but it was packed.
I've never seen some shit like that.
And how many different ones that you go to live?
I went to all of them stuff for London.
How many have with her?
I went to,
uh,
let's see,
I went to Los Angeles,
um,
New York and Toronto.
Dan,
they did London.
So I went on a Aa and the biggest,
what?
Toronto.
I've never seen anything like it,
man.
Really?
Never.
Wow.
People hanging off the rafters to get a piece of his nuts.
Scary shifts.
No one like him.
It's weird.
You know there's a lot of great fighters right now,
but there's no one that has the same enigmatic persona,
this fucking quality that makes everybody want to be around them.
No one on the planet.
I just,
no one.
Even a close second.
There's never been a close second has the Nah,
Nah,
like as far as like popularity,
he's like the biggest by combat sports athlete ever because who else could go
from one sport to the next the way he did?
No,
it was just perfect timing.
Perfect style,
but the talent right now at 55 and 70 I again,
I was looking at 70 I'm like,
oh my God,
the EOC is operating at such a high level.
Talent wise,
it's nuts in certain divisions,
other divisions.
It's Jesus guys.
We need some line.
Do you think you could ever talk George and to fight and Connor a hundred
percent I'm telling you Joe at one 70 why?
I'm telling you when I tell you my guys who are super close to George at their
plan is Woodley Conner.
Now,
a lot has to happen and these guys are,
you know what I mean,
brother?
Amen.
Woodley Chi.
If George comes back and beats Tyron Woodley,
first of all,
that would submit him as the goat.
He's the goat already.
Let's be honest.
Who you coming back at 36 and winning the middleweight title,
moving up,
finishing him,
finishing pound,
playing him asleep.
But it's still like,
that's accomplishment goat versus like technique.
Goat technique.
Goat is mighty mouse.
Who's landing last fight.
And you always go through that.
Nobody like that.
Look at George's resume.
Yeah.
And,
and,
and you're talking about non Usada days.
It's true.
When it was the wild fucking West.
That's creotine light.
That's a question.
No worries about creatine in the bag.
I gotta wrap this up.
[inaudible]
okay.